m
la plupart du temps c'est de cette façon
là que laurianne commencé journée
allait de soi
ouais
avec clémentine
[Musique]
elles viennent chaque jour à 8 heures du
matin pour profiter des ses notes ses
trous d'eau douce qui ressemble à des
piscines naturelles en plein milieu de
la jungle rien de mieux que venir sauter
dans cet orgue glacial avant d'aller
travailler comme ça ça donne plus
l'énergie et puis tu es motivé pour une
grosse journée sous la chaleur des
tropiques non mais c'est incroyable on
est déjà très bien enfin pour avoir le
cul la routine métro-boulot-dodo à paris
y a pas plu du tout il y a encore deux
ans
lauriane et clémentine vivait et
travaillait en france mais très vite
toutes les deux ont eu envie de larguer
les amarres
ailleurs diva avec comme bagage une
sérieuse expérience en hôtellerie elles
ont tenté leur chance dans le dernier
endroit à la mode au mexique toulouse
clémentine se souvient de sa première
impression en arrivant sur cette route
de plage
effet whaou direct et j'ai su que
c'était là j'ai su que c'était là que
j'avais répété et que j'avais un truc à
faire ici toutes les deux oui du flair
bah c'est pas le plan
ci lauriane salut tout le monde en
arrivant c'est qu'elle n'est pas une
simple employée ici c'est la chef
d'orienne à del intégrés mais là elle
est gérante de cet hôtel de luxe en bord
de plage
clémentine elle en dirige le restaurant
et elles ont toutes les deux seulement
27 ans
leur jolie destinée doit beaucoup à cet
endroit considéré aujourd'hui comme un
des plus beaux au monde situé sur la
côte est du mexique
tulu main
cette ancienne cité maya qui se jette
dans la mer des caraïbes est devenu
depuis quelques années le refuge des
stars et des vacanciers branché
on n'y a vu entre autres leonardo
dicaprio
sienna miller
ou encore richard jr
tulum ses 30000 habitants et une seule
et unique route qui longe l'océan sur 5
km avec d'un côté de petits hôtels de
plage bohème et chic
de l'autre la jungle vierge à perte de
vue
ici c'est l'anti cancun pas de tourisme
de masse ni de bars d'hôtel ce morceau
de paradis perdus a longtemps été le
secret le mieux gardé des connaisseurs
mais aujourd'hui il est convoité par de
plus en plus de français
[Musique]
tulum c'est d'abord un océan émeraude à
30 degrés toute l'année
c'est tout de suite ce qui alimente et
cédric ce moniteur de kitesurf de 33 ans
après avoir beaucoup voyagé et
enseignait le kite à des stars de la
silicon valley comme le patron de google
il a posé ses valises ici il y a dix ans
balue la salle st gall atterrissage
avec inigo son employé ils sont
aujourd'hui les seuls à proposer des
cours aux touristes mon bureau c'est ça
voilà ça elle inhibe brûlées soit son
bureau et quand on a du vent eh ben
c'est ça on est on est juste là les gens
y viennent ont leurs palmes êtes
intéressés par le calq on a pas de
réservation oui parfois on parle
directement une enseigne
et sacchi
c'est magique une vie simple au rythme
de la nature qu'il veut désormais offrir
à son petit garçon tu ouvres la porte
moreau
gaël est né ici d'une maman mexicaine
depuis cédric et elles sont séparées et
il a la garde de son petit garçon une
semaine sur deux
[Musique]
tous les matins au réveil c'est un peu
comme si c'était les vacances
le petit garçon prend son verre de lait
au comptoir avant de partir à l'école
- enfin je vous mets je révèle pouvoir
vivre en face de la mer et tout ça
lui les mais ici point de passer sans
encombre cette chance là
aujourd'hui c'est un jour particulier
pour son fils il ya tout le monde que
c'est d'appeler mon rang c'est son
anniversaire
[Musique]
à voir la vie douce même avec un travail
prenant c'est aussi ce qui attire et
lauriane
ccnb hype et la beauté ya là-bas saga
des restaurants et chèques et viennent
comme clémentine kwal bassam et l île
montana la ligue à dallas mais ni
d'anormal congo théia et las cobas
hockey depuis deux ans elle gère ici une
équipe de 40 personnes ce sont les
propriétaires de l'hôtel américains qui
ont été séduits par son enthousiasme et
son jeune âge et lui ont offert le poste
ici on a plus d'opportunités parce que
si vous voulez nous on arrive on est
étranger bon moi j'ai une carrière
décolle de commerce qu'on a des études
type master ce que malheureusement
beaucoup de mexicains n'ont pas
l'opportunité d'avoir avec eux on a des
opportunités incroyables car lauriane ne
dirige pas n'importe quel hôtel cet
endroit a été classé l'année dernière 3e
plus bel hôtel de plage au monde c'est
19/20 galop de luxe sont noyés dans la
végétation
avec des terrasses vue sur jungle ou sur
la mer des caraïbes
[Musique]
combien radio la clientèle est
majoritairement américaines et ne
regardent pas à la dépense pour cette
chambre une des moins chères de l'hôtel
avec sa baignoire extérieur il faut
compter 1000 euros la nuit
[Musique]
vous avez les petites lumières le petit
vin le soir on vous met du sel pour vous
relaxer et du coup c'est vraiment un
avantage ou si vous voulez boire quelque
chose sur votre terrasse est vraiment un
petit plus de ces chambres dans la 5
comme ça certaines suites affiche 2300
euros la nuit et pourtant l'hôtel est
complet toute l'année car lauriane et
son équipe ont réussi à mettre au point
un concept qui fait fureur ici les
vacances qui soigne
la mer
la jungle
que demander de plus donc ça c'est mon
petit endroit préféré
après un massage après une petit une
thérapie on peut faire monter le client
pour qu'ils se reposent ou qui lui offre
une petite boisson rafraîchissante un
petit shot de jus ici on joue à fond la
carte du sein et du bio au restaurant
d'abord avec clémentine
oh là là jeune chef a dû apprendre à ses
40 employés principalement des mexicains
à cuisiner light
pour notre pain et notre pain vegan en
cappadoce
on utilise des graines de chia comics à
une loge une sorte de gel même posture
que l'heure et ça fait un point noir qui
est délicieux et qui est surtout beatles
quand tous les gens qu'on et
d'intolérance c'est vraiment parfait
mais à tulum manger sain fait partie
d'un concept plus globale les clientes
majoritairement américaines mais de plus
en plus française viennent ici pour
faire une retraite spirituelle
la séance de yoga chamanique est ce
qu'il y a de plus tendance en ce moment
parfois il faut redémarrer un ordinateur
pour qu'il fonctionne mieux et bien là
on va redémarrer votre cerveau
alessandra la chamane utilisent les
vibrations pour rééquilibrer le système
nerveux des participantes
un kit de vacances scène et chic qui a
permis à clémentine et lauriane de se
faire une place au soleil et ça n'est
pas prêt de s'arrêter le mexique a connu
l'année dernière une année touristique
record rien qu'à toulouse 30 % de
réservations en plus et ça se voit
des quartiers entiers sont en train de
sortir de la jungle pour accueillir ces
touristes
ces briques le prof de kite a vu
l'ancienne cité maya se transformer en
direct sous ses yeux
ici il y avait déjà deux ans trois ans
il y avait rien absolument rien enfin il
ya six mois de cela il y avait rien là
ici il ya huit mois de ça y avait rien
du tout d'accord donc c'est ça la vie
amicale pour le moment c'est pas près de
s'arrêter non plus c'est pas près de
s'arrêter le jeune papa s'est décidé à
prendre sa part du gâteau il construit
ici un complexe résidentiel de 350 m²
donc là c'est un filet à mac moi je suis
un gros fan des hamacs et c'est la
partie bibliothèque
cinéma avec toutes les choses qui pend
en tout trois appartements qu'il louera
bientôt aux touristes son père et son
frère l'ont aidé à financer le projet
tous les deux convaincus de rentrer
largement dans leurs frais
avec le kite que je fais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui nous demandent des logements
sur toulon et
la façon dont je travaille c'est un mois
je fais que du privé donc ici c'est moi
je vous cherchez donc debout fournit
tous les endroits où aller nous
apprendre kite vous fait les tours je
vais envoyer mes amis pour faire la
plonge et je le sais pas cédric est
confiant avant même que son complexe
soit achevée la valeur du terrain a déjà
quadruplé
un pays de cocagne où tout est abondance
c'est aussi l'impression qu'à lucinda
lorsqu'elle est arrivée à toulouse il ya
quatre ans après quelques années passées
à travailler pour un tour operator cette
tourangelle de 38 ans s'est installé ici
pour devenir wedding planneuse juste au
moment où la demande explose est
il ya un gros gros effet mode surtout
avec les new yorkais et les gens de los
angeles et san francisco
moi je reçois plus d'une vingtaine de
demandes par jour pour les mariages
c'est de la folie il n'y a pas assez de
samedi dans l'année les clients de sinda
travaille principalement dans la mode le
cinéma ils exigent pour leur mariage les
plus beaux endroits du coin ce qui est
compliqué car à tulum la moitié des
plages sont protégés
selon les saisons
à 8h15 heure de musique ou de lumière
parce qu'il ya des tortues donc c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'expliquer à vos
clients qui ont payé 100 mille dollars
leur mariage cas 8 heures le dit doit
partir parce que les tortues forte les
tortues ne sont pas le seul problème de
sinda ici les hôteliers se sont
tellement enrichi ces dernières années
qu'ils rechignent désormais à travailler
plus
pour organiser un mariage dans cet hôtel
cindy a dû être d'abord dans les petits
papiers de la propriétaire le
relationnel ici il ya quoi comme ça que
ça marche l'argent en baptisant nous
c'est à ça qu'il est tout à fait c'est
secondaire vraiment vous demander un
service quand vous emmenez vos clients
même cédé archi milliardaire vous leur
demandez un service donc si vous aime
bien vous travaillez sinon vous les
saouler et ils vous le disant il n'y a
pas de souci s'est pas caché
et pourtant les mariages dont s'occupe
sinda coûte rarement moins de 100000
euros las vegas et les gars bons
rails et le camino est ainsi reportée
selon florès
hi hi mais savez comme tel tas patate
pour ce prix là elle promet le comble du
gypse est le style que toutes les
américaines branchies s'arrachent en
faut imaginer on va tout changer un
lacet la piste de danse donc on est en
train de voir piste de danse en bois
avec les lumières tout autour on va y
avoir des langes et on met des immenses
pouf des fleurs des bougies ont
transformé l'endroit
des mariages comme celui ci sinda on
organise 12 à 15 par an
[Musique]
batterie
de quoi lui assurer une vie plus que
confortable
maison que en un an chaque année je
préfère acheter une maison si je voulais
mais une maison ici un pas en france un
appartement
quand la journée de travail a été
fructueuse sinda s'offrent en général un
petit cadeau
elle rejoint ses amis français salo t'as
pas le talent pour contempler le coucher
de soleil sur la jungle
c'est cette heure-là que le rien et
clémentine aux deux jeunes gérante
d'hôtel préfère ce qu'elle appelle les
heures mystique on les fait au milieu de
la jungle
entouré deux totems et du rituel
[Musique]
lien
les voies pour le connaître l'heure le
rituel les nantais
legault bals d'antan
incroyable
[Musique]
cinq ans
il y a trente ans tulum était encore un
petit village de 500 habitants c'est
cette dernière a mis sa population a
triplé et tout indique que la fête ne
fait que commencer